hello everyone this is amir from
audioscience review
welcome to another episode of inside uh
your high resolution music this is by
request again
to look at the free samples that
the lin records provides for free
so feel free to go to this url and
download and play with the same files
there are three tracks here i've
downloaded the highest quality available
which is
192 kilohertz uh 24-bit uh
samples i have brought those into
adobe audition and i'm going to go ahead
and play these for you one at a time and
let's see what we discover
so oops let me get this to be at the
beginning
so there we go pausing this
uh it's a piano piece we immediately see
usual problems
uh these ultrasonic tones are there uh
four over my count interesting enough
the frequency is actually different in
different channels
blue is one channel red is the other
channel and
so they're actually picking up different
frequencies rather than the same
frequencies so different problems
there i don't have an explanation for
them again they could be
crt monitor scans and
other ultrasonic sources in the
environment
other than that we have a slightly
rising noise floor which is some kind of
noise shaping happening not
not much to talk about but but it's
there
um playing the track again
[Music]
we see that piano really doesn't have
much of a
spectrum as ultrasonics
go
i'd say it's about 20 20 20 kilos to 25
kilohertz
looking at the heat map we see that
above
about this level or so it's all black so
there's really no spectrum in here
so this could have been sampled at 88
kilohertz
uh without any problems and at 88
kilohertz we would have
cut off at 44 kilos here not have any of
this rising nose floor
or these peaks so uh same story as other
music that we've examined disappointing
that these are there fortunate levels
are not
so extreme but the frequencies are quite
high so
let's move on to the second track they
provided
and again let me pull this to the
beginning and let's play that
immediately we see the issues rising out
of the noise floor this is an organ
piece
uh i can't see any reason for this to be
there this and the other peaks
let it continue to play
so we see the usual problems
peaks in here not lower frequencies are
more bothersome
so this is 26 kilohertz this beak is
there this one's there
notice it's just in one channel again
not in the other channel
likewise we have one channel here
picking up some garbage here and not in
the other one
uh moving this to the end let's see what
happens when there's silence
oops so again even during silence we
have all these peaks
uh it's just disappointing how common
this problem is
clearly there's just no attention paid
to uh
cleaning up ultrasonic uh people
probably just listen to the clips and if
they don't hear something
they go ahead and record and produce
this content and ship it to us
more hygiene is definitely necessary
let's go to the third clip the third
clip
and see what's going on there
it's quite fascinating here check out
the scalloping
uh comb filtering type of response this
isn't that's in here
we've got one here here here here here
and it continues on
uh i just can't tell you what's causing
that um unless this
is the uh response of the anti-aliasing
filter and it's actually
some of this signal here that's showing
up here
as a lower amount of uh
lower amplitude than goes on here but
quite unusual
it's not something i've seen in
recordings before
so let's continue to play
there's really no doubt that this is all
there and
you know it's not correlated with music
when music comes it overwhelms it
but as it's there as a background sort
of
tones that keep going on and on we have
our usual rising nose floral so
uh because of noise shaping
what this southern peak was
yeah it looks like there's actually
musical information the microphone has
pretty good bandwidth and he's trying to
struggle and to push above this noise
floor if this rising noise floor wasn't
there and we didn't have this garbage
this is a quite a wide bandwidth uh
recording as far as the microphones are
concerned
so pulling this all the way to the end
and see what happens during the silence
again
again we see all this statically there
so definitely definitely not good
uh disappointing on multiple fronts you
know in addition to the usual peaks that
we have now we have this
tons of spectrum over here that scallops
up and down
uh some of these are awfully close to
the audible band
i mean check out this one it's right at
20 kilohertz
even this one might be suspect so
you know this is supposed to be silence
and instead we have this
all the way down to 14 15 kilohertz
something is generating
this spray of harmonics uh
yeah thinking about this may actually be
a switching power supply of some sort
maybe powering uh
some amplifiers something in the signal
path that's generating
all this it could also even be their
lighting system actually
thinking about it out loud could be some
kind of
switching power supply that's powering
led lights
of the sword that's generating all of
this noise
i definitely wouldn't call this high
resolution music so
have these offered as a sample of what
high resolution music could provide is
disappointing
subjectively none of this sounds like it
needs
high resolution piano music and
vocals and and oregon wouldn't be my
choice if
something that that needs ultra high
spectrum
i know there's some arguments about
timing resolution what have you we'll
leave that to
a future episode but again disappointing
um for samples i expect to see
pristine and clean
musical samples provided to us not stuff
that looks like this
so that's it again this is amir from
audiosciencereview.com
talk to you later in a future video
bye-bye